die dramatische Suche nach einem
tragischen Badeunfall in
Nordrhein-Westfalen darum geht es jetzt
und das hier sind die Bilder die
dazugehören ein siebenjähriger Junge
spielt am Ufer des Rheins bei Barl einem
Stadtteil von Duisburg sein Vater ist
nur einen Moment lang unaufmerksam die
Bugwelle eines vorbeifahrenden Schiffes
reißt das Kind offenbar in die Fluten
der Vater versucht noch verzweifelt sein
Sohn zu retten wird dabei aber selbst
unter Wasser gezogen eine Frau die wohl
dazu gehört ist ebenfalls im Wasser kann
sich selbst ans Ufer retten zwei Stunden
lang suchen 57 Einsatzkräfte mit dabei
Feuerwehr Polizei DLRG Helikopter und
Rettungsbote sind im Einsatz ja sogar
eine jetski-einheit und Taucher suchen
die zwei vermissten bislang ergebnislos
unsere Reporter Leonard Gisberts ist vor
Ort in Duisburg Wahl gestern Abend wurde
ja die Suche dann eingestellt die
Lichtverhältnisse haben es auch einfach
nicht mehr zugelassen wie ist die
momentane Lage bei dir
ja also die große Suchaktion ist heute
noch nicht angelaufen wir haben auch
eben noch mal mit den Behörden
gesprochen die konnten uns da auch noch
keine genaueren Aussagen zu tätigen die
sind da glaube ich aktuell noch so
scheint ist in der Findungsphase wir
haben allerdings jetzt hier vor Ort wir
stehen jetzt auch gerade an dem Becken
wo der Junge und der Vater gestern
reingezogen wurden mehrfach die
Wasserschutzpolizei gesehen die mit
Booten ja gerade die Uferbereiche auf
und abfährt und auch noch mal schaut ob
nicht vielleicht doch irgendwo eine eine
Person gefunden werden kann aber das ist
so der aktuelle Stand der Dinge hier
Leonard was weiß man inzwischen über die
vermissten was ist bekannt
also es handelt sich um ein
siebenjährigen Jungen und seinen Vater
der Junge hatte gestern hier in diesem
Becken hinter mir am Wasser gespielt
dieses Becken ist aufgrund der
anhaltenden Trockenheit vom Rhein
eigentlich erst freigegeben worden was
aber nicht heißt das ist freigegeben ist
zum schwimmen weil der Rhein ist nun mal
die Autobahn der Wasserstraßen und der
Junge wurde dann aufgrund eines
schiffszugs in das Wasser hineingezogen
der Vater war am Uferbereich war in
vollen Klamotten und ist dann direkt
hinterher gesprungen beide sind dann
laut Augenzeugen sehr schnell unter
Wasser gezogen worden und seitdem auch
nicht mehr gesehen worden hat man dann
überhaupt noch Hoffnung die beiden
vermissten tatsächlich Leben zu finden
leider nein also das war gestern Abend
schon nach den zwei Stunden relativ klar
dass da eigentlich keine Hoffnung mehr
besteht und das ist keine Rettung
sondern eine Bergung werden würde die
Stimmung war dementsprechend noch
angespannt und auch sehr bedrückt also
selbst bei gestandenen Einsatzkräften
merkte man das lässt die nicht ganz kalt
und das ist auch sehr verständlich wenn
man sich das mal das ganze Szenario hier
angeschaut vor allem weil halt auch die
Angehörigen und auch die Mutter hier
noch vor Ort waren die das ja auch mit
gesehen hat
vielen Dank für diese aktuellen
Eindrücke von der Suchaktion in Duisburg
Leonard giesberg
[Musik]